- Hey Kari, oh man, really
came in hot that time.
Everything's so crazy, right?
There's a lot of true
stuff, a lot of fake stuff.
You're the head of the
video research department
here at Buzzfeed motion pictures,
you know all the answers.
- I know how to find the answers.
- Kari's got it, lets do this.
- I got it.
(triumphant, rising music)
So the first thing that was circulating
after the inauguration is this image.
♫ Look at this photograph
- [Kari] Where it looks like Obama
is touching Melania's butt.
- He is touching her butt.
That's not just looks like it.
Look at it, you can
tell, photos don't lie.
- Well, I think we found
that sometimes they do.
- God damn it, why are
people making fake photos?
- I mean, I think they're
trying to manipulate
people's ideas about Obama, specifically,
with this one, with other
ones it could be other people.
- Would they like to tappa dat ass?
That's what they want to
make everybody believe.
- I think so.
- I feel like Republicans
would like that! I don't know.
- Look at what the
caption of this photo is.
- What will feminists say about this?
- So I think they are going
after feminists with this one.
- I'm gonna say right
now, I'd say both Obamas
are gettin' a little friendly.
That is a low back,
it's a low back placement.
- It kinda is a low back,
yeah.
- Get her Michelle!
- Obama isn't actually
touching her butt though.
That's the thing, this is Photoshopped.
You can kinda see like
his arm right there,
it's not the best Photoshop ever.
- Well it could just be an extra arm.
Obama got a lot of work done.
I mean, he might have a secret third arm.
- Unfortunately though,
we can actually compare
it to the live video of the inauguration
where it very clearly,
his arm is way higher.
- And this isn't like a few frames after
he was grabbing that butt?
Here they come in, don't worry, it's all
gonna be okay, you're gonna be just fine.
- [Kari] And then just a momentary touch.
- Oh yeah, that was it.
- Just a quick little touch.
- Just a hey, we're here.
- Yeah.
- That was actually very sweet
of the Obamas.
- Yeah, it was nice.
- Did they touch Donald the same way?
Grab that butt.
- [Kari] I don't think there's
a lot of grabbin' happenin'.
- And there's that new picture out,
he's got a big ol' butt.
Now that's a butt worth touchin'.
Okay, so he didn't really touch her butt.
- Nope.
- Too bad.
- Yep, so that one's fake.
The next thing is, it's been going around
that Kellyanne Conway
did stand up in the '90s.
- Kellyanne, she's hilarious.
I see her all the time, she's
really perfected her act.
So she started in 1998.
- Everybody was talking about
how she tried to do stand up
but the real thing is that
she actually only did it
once as a part of a D.C. charity event.
But she still did do it.
We have the video of her doing it.
- So this is where she got her inspiration
of how she could be such a comedic icon,
such a big character.
- Who's to say, it does look like she's
wearing a feather boa in this.
So, yeah.
- That's funny, that's funny.
Oh, so you wanna watch it?
- I mean, we can watch it.
- We shouldn't watch it,
we could be biased.
- I already love her.
- Yeah, you're a big fan.
- You clearly question her.
Why don't we get some comedians in here,
have them review it.
- Yeah.
Makes sense.
- Hey, Garrick!
- You know everybody's
wondering about my leg
it's the first thing they ask,
Kellyanne, what happened to your leg?
I'm like, well everybody
heard I was gonna be in this
comedy show and they're
like, break a leg, so I did.
- No! (laughing)
She sucks so hard.
- [Kari] It's a charity event.
- Okay, you clearly are
biased, get out of here
you're biased, you
can't appreciate comedy.
If you like it, you can stay.
♫ Got the pundit blues
- [Garrick] I can't do it.
- Alright, get back in here Kari.
You know what, I'll be honest with you.
This is light, right?
The first one was about
Obama touching the butt.
The second one was about
Kellyanne Conway doing stand up.
What is one thing that's going on
that maybe people aren't
freaking out about enough?
- This is a crazy thing that
happened overnight last night.
Trump fired the acting Attorney General
after she ordered the Justice Department
to not defend this travel ban because
she said it was unconstitutional.
- So she's on Trump's team,
- She's supposed to be.
- and she just be like, I can't do this,
and he's like, you're fired.
- But weirdly enough Jeff Sessions,
the person who is currently
about to be confirmed
in Congress as the new Attorney General,
he kind of told her to
do exactly what she did.
He literally told her to
defy a president's orders
if the views the president
wants to execute are unlawful.
- So now we've got
somebody else, she's gone.
We've got this guy named Dana.
- Yep, this is Dana.
- Look at Dana.
- This is Dana.
I think it is like the byline would be,
General Dana Boente,
just happy to be here!
- He probably is, he was
just like a federal judge
in Virginia before this,
this is a huge promotion.
- So then we have Sessions coming in,
and then, maybe he'll
stay, maybe he won't,
maybe we'll get him.
You'll know by the time
you watch this video if
Sessions is in power, you'll
know better than we do, right?
- This is true, we're in the past.
- This is so upsetting, right?
I just wanted this video to be about
touching butts and a
comedian's rise to fame.
(laughing)
That's all I wanted.
- I'm sorry.
- I want all these videos,
okay, to only be about butts.
- I mean, I can't promise that.
There's a lot of stuff going on, Keith.
- Obama, open invite,
you can touch my butt.
Michelle, too, you can also touch my butt.
Melania, you can touch my butt.
Trump, sure, why not.
- It's like open season
on Keith's butt right now.
- Any politician may touch my butt,
I'm gonna put that out there right now
so there's never a controversy later on,
you can use this as the fact
saying no, Keith, in 2017 said,
any politician could touch his butt.
- I can't wait to use this as a source.
- Oh, I can't wait for it to be a source.
So, now that we've created a new source
I feel like we've done a real job here.
I'm Keith.
- I'm Kari
- And this is What is Real?
Right? That's what we call this?
- I think so.
- Great.
(triumphant, rising music)